the question is where is the nearest
black hole can we visit
it and uh you know i wrote a paper
with my undergraduate student amir siraj
suggesting that perhaps you know there
could be if there is one in the solar
system we can detect it
because um i don't know if you heard but
there is a claim that maybe there is a a
planet nine in the solar system um
because we see some anomalies at the
outer parts of the solar system so some
people suggested maybe there is a planet
out there that
was not yet detected so people searched
for it didn't find it
it weighs roughly five times the mass of
the earth and we said okay maybe you
can't find it because it's a black hole
and that was formed early in the
universe
is that part so where do you stand up it
could be that the dark matter is made of
black holes of this mass you know we
don't know what the dark matter is made
of you could
it could be the black holes so we said
but there is an experimental way to test
it
and the way to do it is because uh
is there is the oort cloud of icy
rocks in the outer solar system and if
you imagine a black hole there
every now and then a rock will pass
close enough to the black hole
to be disrupted by the very strong
gravity
close to the black hole and that would
produce a flare
that you can observe and we calculated
how frequently these flares should occur
and with lsst on the vera rubin
observatory we found that you can
actually
test this hypothesis that's brilliant
and if you don't see flares
then you can put limits on the existence
of a black hole in the solar system
it would be extremely exciting if there
was a black hole if planet nine was a
black hole because
we could visit it you know and we can
examine it
uh and it will not be a matter of um
you know an object that is very removed
from us
another thing i should say is it's
possible that the black hole affected
life on earth
the black hole at the center of the
milky way
how you know that black hole right now
is dormant
it's very faint but we know that it
flares
when a star like the sun comes close to
it
the star will be spaghettified basically
becomes
a stream of gas like a spaghetti
and then the gas would fall into the
black hole and there would be a flare
and this process happens once every 10
000 years or so so we expect that
you know these flares to occur every 10
000 years
but we also see evidence for the
possibility that
gas clouds were disrupted by the black
hole because
the stars that are close to the black
hole are residing in a single
or two planes and the only way you can
get that is if they formed out of a disk
of gas
just like the planets in the solar
system formed so
there is evidence that gas fell into the
black hole and powered
possibly a flare and these flares
produce x-rays and ultraviolet radiation
that could damage life if if the earth
was close enough to the center of the
galaxy
where we are right now it's not very
risky for us
but there is a uh
theoretical argument that says the solar
system the sun
was closer to the galactic center early
on and then it migrated
outwards so maybe maybe in the early
stage of the solar system the conditions
you know were affected shaped by these
flares
of the black hole at the center of the
galaxy and that's why for the first two
billion years there wasn't
any oxygen in the atmosphere you know
who knows but
um it's just interesting to think that
you know from a
theoretical concept that einstein
resisted in 1939
it may well be that you know black holes
have influence on our life and that you
know it's just like discovering that
some
stranger affected your family
and in a way your life
and you know if that happens to be the
case a second nobel prize should be
given not
not for just the discovery of this black
hole at the center of the galaxy but
perhaps for the nobel prize in chemistry
for the effect that it had
for the for the interplay that resulted
in some kind of
uh yeah so yeah the chemical effect
biology i mean all those kinds of things
in in terms of uh
the emergence of uh life and the
creation of a habitable
environment that's so fascinating and of
course like you said dark matter like
black holes have some they could be the
dark matter in principle yes
uh we don't know what the dark matter is
at the moment
you